that's
Liubov kovalyova feels compelled to
speak about her pain again and again she
tells how her son vladislav was executed
in March three years ago he was 26 years
old his mother doesn't know where to go
with her grief she doesn't know where
her son was buried we don't have a grave
that's why when our neighbors heard that
Vlad was no longer alive
they laid flowers right in front of our
door and now here they are he was such a
good-looking intelligent boy a good boy
Vladislav kovalyova and a friend were
accused of setting off a bomb in the
Minsk subway in April 2011 15 people
died in the attack some human rights
activists regard the proceedings against
them as a show trial based on coerced
false confessions but they were both
found guilty sentenced to death and shot
in the back of the neck Liubov kovalyova
is convinced her son was an innocent
victim of arbitrary justice in the style
of Belarusian despot Alexander
Lukashenko
in our case there were specific
instructions to find them guilty and
kill them maybe they wanted to
intimidate our society maybe there was a
political background but he teachers
came not even the death sentences were
carried out in March 2012 in this prison
in the middle of Belarus his capital
Minsk
this animated film shows how the last
minutes of blood is laughs life may have
played out the human rights group Vesna
had the film made to make people think
about capital punishment
Vesna activists maintained contact with
the many grieving mothers who are not
even allowed to bury their son's human
rights activities are very difficult in
authoritarian Belarus and president
Lukashenko says the death penalty is
indispensable in the fight against crime
we call for the abolition of the death
penalty because when a country has the
death penalty any procedural error can
have dramatic consequences it can lead
to taking an innocent life a man living
in Berlin knows Belarus is death row
from the inside a leg Alki EV he headed
Belarus's execution squad for five years
then in 2001 he ran afoul of his
country's justice system and received
political asylum in Germany in his old
job he was in charge of the shootings of
more than 130 people he says he didn't
realize how cruel the death penalty was
until he lived in Germany he followed
Liubov kovalyova struggle for a pardon
for her son Shengo is never pardoned to
anyone but in this case he could have
done it this boy had no blood on his
hands he was found guilty only of aiding
and abetting but they shot him dead he
should have had a chance for a pardon
three men were executed in Belarus again
last year president Lukashenko rejected
their appeals and petitions for clemency
Liubov kovalyova intends to continue her
struggle against the death penalty in
Belarus there should be no more cases
like ask innocent people should no
longer be condemned
just because someone thinks they have an
advantage from it
I don't want more mothers to suffer
Liubov kovalyova hopes to learn someday
where her vladislav now lies then she'll
have a place to take her grief